thank you
[Music]
cardi B and offset's daughter culture
Starstruck meeting Princess Ariel AKA
Hallie Bailey it feels absolutely
amazing to officially be a Disney
princess I mean I think that it's
something that we have all just had in
our dreams it was a daddy-daughter date
night for the rapper and his two
princesses at The Little Mermaid
Premiere
right here sweetheart that's
four-year-old culture whom he shares
with cardi an eight-year-old Kalia
offsets daughter from a previous
relationship perfectly dressed for the
occasion in gowns now the musicians also
giving Regal Vibes too
on the blue carpet the girls first met
Hallie's Sister Chloe and shared this
sweet moment captured by Good Morning
America you do have red hair like my
sister
I don't know how but I know something's
starting right now
if I get chills to know that all of
those beautiful girls will be able to
see proper representation whether you're
black or white or anything like that
you'll be able to look at my sister and
say I can be anything that I want to be
no matter what the world tells me is
acceptable and there could not be a more
perfect Ariel then once inside culture
meets Ariel herself with the Daily Mail
sharing this adorable interaction
[Music]
you never think like it would actually
happen I just am really grateful to be
in this position for Hallie being an
inspiration to little girls like culture
and Kalia is special I think of the
little girl that's still in me honestly
and it heals that girl inside of me and
to watch them feel like they have
representation and someone to look to to
know that they deserve to be in those
spaces too is so important
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got laid
eggs when you came in you had some ideas
about representation and how you wanted
to show up yes to the audience you
wanted to wear your natural hair and I
loved that was there anything else that
you said like I need to make sure I stay
true to myself in this way yes well I
think naturally I just really tried my
best to stay true to myself
and every choice that I would make in
acting and especially in the songs
me
[Music]
someday I'll be
well Hallie sure made a splash on
culture and kalia's night out a dream
come true meeting a Disney princess
[Music]